ils se retrouvent ici chaque matin
depuis des décennies on l'appelle la
table des menteurs ils sont retraités
conteur d'histoires et bon vivant
on s'est fait plusieurs années je dis
ouf ils ont acquises entre nous il
digère mal les attaques du gouvernement
faune contre leur langue et leur
identité
la suppression du commissariat aux
services en français et l'annulation du
projet d'université francophones à
toronto décision renversée ces dernières
semaines buté sur 6 pour eux la crise
linguistique provincial s'invite dans la
campagne électorale fédérale
sa pénurie des vins qu'ils convoitent et
jeux 6 et provincial mais c'est encore
dit fédérer qui travaillent ensemble
mais le parti libéral joe était imparti
de favoriser canadiens français
les conservateurs n'ont jamais vraiment
été automatiquement
ils partiront
on doit choisir ce que vous voyez sur la
défense des droits des francophones ou
sur l'économie sur la santé ce cocktail
un vote pour plus que les droits des
francophones de terminus l'élection par
paul insultes
la circonscription de glengarry prescott
russell est un bastion de la
francophonie ontarienne berceau de la
résistance aux compressions on y
dévoilait la semaine dernière un
monument en hommage aux bâtisseurs
francophone c'est un rappel que on ne
doit jamais arrêté de se battre pour nos
droits et pour faire reconnaître notre
existence
la question linguistique leur apparaît
comme essentiel dans la campagne
électorale
par contre aucun parti n'a encore pris
de grands engagements à cet égard
donc oui c'est une des composantes qui
tirait très important ma culture ma vie
elle a la culture de l'excusé enfants
puis ils vont c'est qu'avant de parler
en français donc je dirais que oui c'est
50% de ce que je recherche
et c'est chez eux que plein d'autres
enjeux comme les enjeux climatiques
les enjeux pour l'éducation puis tout ce
que vous êtes fier d'être francophone
libéraux qui ont arraché la
circonscription aux conservateurs il ya
quatre ans joue la carte francophones à
fond sophie grégoire la conjointe de
justin trudeau accompagnait le candidat
local pour l'occasion et soyons clair le
parti libéral a toujours été une alliée
dans la protection la promotion de la
langue francophone française ici au
canada et on va toujours être aux alliés
c'est dans mon n'était rien d'avoir
quelqu'un avec qui je peux bien
travaillé amanda simard a été le visage
de la résistance franco ontarienne la
députée a suivi sa conscience et quitter
le caucus conservateur de dog pound un
siège maintenant comme indépendant
elle croit que les conservateurs d'un
douchez devrait tendre la main aux
francophones
pas seulement au québec je pense que
monsieur doit commencer par dénoncer les
coupures de monsieur fort parce que à
moins que j'aie que chez patou
l'information j'ai pas encore entendu
monsieur tchimou dénoncer les
compressions et pourtant c'est si simple
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
s'entend tous que c'était négatif
aujourd'hui un menu de l'agriculture qui
te fait nommer le militant francophones
et ancien député provincial jean poirier
lui incitent les franco ontariens à la
prudence
justin trudeau n'est peut-être pas
l'allié qu'il prétend être selon lui on
croit qu'il est sympathique mais
le bilan qu'est ce que fait pour les
francophones ils viennent nommer tous
payent pas les franco ontariens mais
pour les francophones hors québec une
lieutenante-gouverneure unilingue
anglais dans la seule province
officiellement bilingue au canada
la constitution est encore apparu depuis
82 la version française est officieuse
et non officiel la loi sur les langues
officielles la tablette à renforcer les
renforcer et moderniser la loi sur les
langues officielles c'est le souhait de
beaucoup de francophones
mais chaque chose en son temps réplique
la table des menteurs pourrait blesser
peut-être politain l'eau notre jeu gagne
en cause daniel mann être protégé de ron
arad est peut-être trop c'est
sympathique menteurs sont déchirés entre
désir de protéger leur identité et peur
de déranger
ils sont comme temps de franco ontarien